so the grift and the corruption are both
coming full circle rudy giuliani has
reportedly discussed a
blanket preemptive pardon from president
donald trump in these last seven weeks
before trump leaves office
trump also reportedly considering
pre-emptive
blanket pardons for three of his
children as well as his son-in-law
jared kushner the new york times can
report
based on multiple sources told about the
conversation
that rudy giuliani as recently as last
week was talking to donald trump about a
pardon
it's not clear as of yet whether rudy
giuliani originally brought it up to
trump or whether trump brought it up to
giuliani
but there have now reportedly been
multiple conversations the most recent
one was last week
donald trump has reportedly not yet
decided what he will do
about pardoning rudy giuliani and the
same questions remain
about trump pardoning jared kushner as
well as his children
ivanka don jr and eric
now trump reportedly not considering a
pardon for tiffany trump i guess he
doesn't expect that she might
uh be charged with anything but the the
immediate question is pardon from what
rudy hasn't even been charged with
anything neither have his children and
that is exactly the question that's
raising the most attention
it's not actually clear what rudy
giuliani might be charged with in the
future
but the fact that it's being discussed
multiple times at the highest levels
is very interesting we know that rudy
was being investigated last summer by
federal investigators for maybe
violating
lobbying law through the work he did
with ukraine but beyond that it's not
exactly clear
now what we do know is that as a general
concept
the idea here is that with regard to his
children and son-in-law at least then it
may be similar with rudy giuliani
donald trump believes that there will be
partisan
investigations and possibly prosecutions
of his children
after he leaves office and so it's not
because from from trump's perspective
it's not that he thinks his kids
committed crimes
it's that he thinks they didn't but they
might be charged with crimes anyway by a
partisan joe biden administration
what you know there's this funny thing
um
trump always projects his
immorality and his do whatever for a
buck
or whatever for revenge sort of attitude
on other people
trump is worried biden would go after
trump's kids
even though they didn't do anything as
far as trump is concerned
because that's exactly what trump would
do if he were joe biden but joe biden
has clearly shown no interest and has
even said
he has no plan to direct his justice
department to do anything of the sort
but a lot of trump's behavior is
motivated by what
trump imagines he would do if in someone
else's position
now rudy giuliani's spokeswoman was
asked
about the seeking a pardon and she said
giuliani can't comment on any
discussions he's had with his client
trump being his client so what we're
talking about here
are blanket broad open-ended
pre-emptive pardons this is very rare
but it has happened in the past
george washington yeah we have to go
back we don't have to go back that far
but one
notable example goes back to george
washington who pardoned
those who were plotting the whiskey
rebellion so that they wouldn't be
prosecuted for treason
uh gerald ford pardoned richard nixon
for all his actions as president now
it is important to remember a few
important things about presidential
pardons number one
they work for federal crimes not state
crimes so if
the southern district of new york as an
example were to bring charges against
rudy or ivanka or whoever we're still
not sure for what but if they did
the pardon from trump wouldn't protect
them there number two
whether preemptive blanket pardons work
is a legal question and what i mean by
that is a president
can do it and in the past these
pre-emptive pardons
have dissuaded anybody from prosecuting
the pardoned individuals like for
example
when gerald ford pardoned richard nixon
the pardon
was challenged legally it was found to
be constitutional
but it was never brought to the supreme
court it is conceivable that a supreme
court could say
a blanket preemptive pardon is not okay
whether it ever gets to the supreme
court is a question
and you know with with the supreme court
we have right now
i'm not sure this supreme court is going
to rule against
blanket preemptive pardons from donald
trump
so that's one part of this now as far as
donald trump is concerned
he just pardoned his convicted former
national security adviser michael flynn
last week
he previously commuted the sentence of
roger stone
he also pardoned less well-known people
now just a funny side note
things are so crazy right now that when
i read the original headline about this
story
i thought maybe rudy and trump talked
about trump pardoning
trump the first headline i saw said
something like
giuliani discussed a preemptive pardon
with trump
that could mean giuliani talked to trump
about trump pardoning rudy
but it could also mean that as his
lawyer giuliani talked to trump about
trump pardoning
himself and a self-pardon is a
completely different story
unclear whether that is something donald
trump could do so the long and short of
it is
rudy wants immunity for everything no
matter what in perpetuity and a sort of
free pass
and that would be for things what let me
see how i can say this the right way
the the pardon can't be for things that
you do after the pardon so in other
words if rudy is pardoned and the next
day commits a federal crime
the legal consensus is that would not be
covered by a presidential pardon
we're going to follow it many pardons
coming from donald trump in the next
seven weeks for sure
i want to let you know that our sponsor
vincero watches is having a massive
holiday sale on all of their products
right now
and you can take advantage of it by
going to davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality
wristwatch really is the perfect way
to add something fresh to your style
whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else vincero is a
brand that has a serious dedication to
the craft of watchmaking which is really
evident when you look closely at their
watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black watch and i love the sleek
minimalist design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wristwatch
from high-end materials but one that
everyday people can afford
and that's why they have over twenty
five thousand
five star reviews because you won't find
a better made watch
for this great of a price anywhere else
you can get big holiday discounts on all
of their products right now and free
shipping when you go to davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video